We are lying to both. We are lying to both lightweight
pilots and heavier pilots. Current standard is testing the
perfect vertical drop and there are loads of problems with this
test. There have been a lot of
feedback over many years about the limitations of their test
and it seems like a new standard is coming out next year which is
not addressing any of those limitations which people
communicating to them. The weight limit, the spine
protection, the horizontal component.
So none of those were solved. They addressed something which
was really not a critical problem and they just totally
avoided answering the hard questions.
We had medical researchers on the team and everyone agreed
that the human body has upper tolerable limit for GERD.
Nevyuk was always sharing the NASA study about the G values
acceleration, explaining we need lower G and lower G And I said,
look, we are looking at the very same NASA study.
The pages say the human body can tolerate this much jerk.
If you go over the jerk, you break the vertebra.
At the very end of this discussion, there were two
reasons why we shouldn't do it. They believe that if we go for
the jerk value, then the harnesses would be very large.
The way it works currently in this sport, we we are in the
dark ages. There are pilots on Brazil World
Championship who still hasn't recovered from vertebral
compression. They have so serious injuries
from just a normal landing on a coroid, which would have not
been a serious issue with the previous generation harnesses.
So if we know for sure that it does not work, these coroid
protectors, they do not protect the pilots.
Hello and welcome back to another episode of Paragliding
at Us. I'm your host Aninder Singh, and
if you have been liking what's coming your way all these weeks,
then please do me a favour, go join our Patreon channel because
we are coming out with a weekly dose of awesomeness there as
well, with a brand new newsletter focused entirely on
flight safety. And now for today's episode, we
have none other than Jolt Arrow with us.
Who is going to throw a lot of interesting light on the topic
of harnesses? Yo, long time man, how's it
going? Thank you very much.
I'm good. How are you?
Good as well. I've been following your chats
on the pilots union and the base camp and everything and it got
me super excited to say the least.
Because you know, your content there had a lot of meaning
behind it. And I think harnesses is one of
those topics which doesn't have a lot of attention that it
deserves compared to the wings in our industry.
So I thought you know who better than you to speak about the
topic of harnesses, man. Thank you.
What's what's your background, Joel?
How do you know so much about harnesses and what have you been
doing in flying so far? So my background is I was always
interested in physics and science and did a degree in
artificial intelligence, but afterwards I went to software
engineering, but I kind of always missed this physical part
and competition. So it was always a big love of
me which I abandoned. And then this topic of viral
lighting harnesses came very actual because it's actually
right now we are in a safety crisis about harnesses.
So I just jumped into it because I found it like it's really
good. It's really good to research and
I think I can find places which no one researched before.
That is so true. I love your sources and the the
formatting and the structure of it.
I think we we do have quite a few learned people in
paragliding but very few of them are professional or semi
professional researchers and their findings and their R&D is
a class apart from what any of us and enthusiasts do in this
regard I believe. Thank you.
I'm trying to really go deep into the independent parts and
I'm, I'm trying to connect those dots together because when I
started it 2 1/2 years ago, when the CIVL invited me for the
working group, I was clueless. Those things which I'm aiming
for like like measuring jerk, the smoothness of the
deceleration was I didn't even know about.
So I learned a lot in those groups.
And then I started researching more and more like how can we
measure those things? Do we need a new equipment?
Do we just calculate the numbers and software like so?
I actually learned a lot in those 2 1/2 years since I joined
that group. And I think at that point I
started going one step further. I was thinking like, OK, this is
not go, not good how it went. What do we need to do?
So that's where I am now. Love it man, and I think the the
reason for this episode is to share some of those learnings
with the audiences who are tuning in to us every week.
Umm, you know, harnesses is a very interesting topic for me
because ever since I started paragliding, to me, harness is
like you're thrown in the sky. Because to me, the place where
you're supposed to sit and make all the responsible decisions to
make sure flight safety remains paramount and the fun remains as
it is. You have to be sitting in a
comfortable place because you're going to be making a lot of
important decisions and be physically active as well.
So what I'm wondering is when it comes for the newer generation
of pilots who are joining the sport and they have to rely on
some other information to make their decisions, can you name
few factors which help in deciding what kind of harness
you want? For me, that's comfort.
But according to you who has been having deep dives on this
topic, few pointers that a new pilot should look for while
picking up a new harness. So at first point, I agree it's
comfort, but it's not just comfort, it's actually safety
because at one point it it matters if you can control your
wing in a turbulent air or not. If you're sliding around in a
harness, then basically you lose a lot of that control.
So, so it's not just quite, I would say it fit.
So fit is like the number one criteria as you said.
In my experience, I found out I could never really test the
harness hanging in a shop. I always have to actually try
it. So sometimes I bought a harness
and I had to sell it after a few flights because in the shop it
was comfortable, but at flight when pushing the speed bar, I'm
kind of pushed into a different place.
So I think the only way to figure out is to have a test
flight. It's about fitness.
But but my research is about the safety.
And for safety we are talking mostly about, I mean there are
two parts of safety. One is the rescue position.
I, I think it's very important. Some lightweight harnesses don't
have the hanging points on the shoulders.
So I think it's super important to use a harness which have the
shoulder hanging points because when you're coming down under a
rescue, that's the most important.
It puts you in the safest position.
Your legs are touching the ground first and you can do this
perfect fall. I'm sorry to interject here.
I would like to quote one of our previous guest.
I don't do not remember if it was Eric Neal or Eric from Neo
fly Neo who owns the brand or or Sahari from the the Beamer 3
inventor reserve parachute. I mean he was not like he owns
the company which owns Beamer 3. They said shoulder hanging
points are like a catastrophical setup in the process of down
planning. So if you're down planning and
if you are being pulled on, on one end, let's say this is the
pilot and this is the head of the pilot and they are being
pulled from here by the reserve and there is a down planning
glider coming in. Then the impact that will most
likely happen when the pilot touches the ground is flat on
his ass and some part of back. Whereas Neil came out with a
stand up harness where he says that you probably touch with
your feet down 1st and hopefully PLF will absorb the remaining
part of it. So I mean those, those are
improvements, but that my alternative is that you can find
some harnesses where the rescue goes on the carabiners and avoid
those. There's a usually I think I can
fly harnesses or lightweight, but the rescue goes on the and
if you are hanging on the carabiners, you're just
basically hitting the ground with your spine with your back.
Yeah. So those ones, those ones you
should, you should avoid those ones with the carabiner mounting
points. And but the one I actually
researched and one I would like to talk more about is there is a
bag protector. So I believe right now the
safest bag protectors are big inflatable airbags, like pre
inflatable, not the ones where there was a time when it was
very popular that you start with with no air in the airbag and
over, I don't know, a minute of flying.
You hope that it inflates itself.
So I'm not I'm not saying those ones, I'm saying the ones which
you inflate at this before take off using the bag or using your
lung, you inflate it, you close the bag and then you're flying
the whole flight with a with a closed bag.
So those, but not all of them are big.
Some of them are tiny, but look for one which is really nice and
big and covers your spine. Those ones are really safe.
So I believe right now one of the safest harnesses on the
market is how I can fly harness from Skywalk the ranging Subs 3.
It's light and it has a really nice and really big and safe
protector. And I did the measurements and
it has some of the lowest acceleration values and lowest
jerk values. So it's a, it's a really safe
harness which has an airbag. And if an airbag is not an
option, then I think the alternative is a good big foam
protector. And at that point, basically you
will have to trust your own instincts about what's a big
one. Like you see a few harnesses,
some of them have a foam, just a tiny, tiny foam just under the
seat plate. Then you can have other
harnesses which have like a nice foam nicely protecting around
your your back and choose something which is a nice foam
harness. If you're going for safety.
Of course these are not the most aerodynamic ones, but these are
nice and safe harnesses. You know what, I'm going to just
share my screen here to compare because to me, foam visually
looks more safer. You know, it's, it's that it's
more dense, It can, it's more rugged and it has been long
trusted by humans for various uses and impact absorptions
happened to be one of them compared to airbags, which are
more or less a one time use. And of course they're delicate
and they have their own limitations in different ways.
But what I want to do is I want to compare Skywalk X Alps range
3 versus Woody Valley XR7. My first harness was a GTO Lite
one. The foam protector in the GTO
Lite 1 is pretty thick, like I don't know how many centimeters,
but it's a fairly thick protector which is under your
ass, so it's not behind your back.
So what I want to do is I want you to tell me what are the big
differences between this one and this one because I am on the
official website of Woody Valley right now.
XR7 seemed the most robust harness to me that our industry
had seen before submarines came. This is the protector of the
skywalk, so I think this is a much better image.
So I think what everyone can figure out is how much it
protects back on your spine because we will spend more time
talking about it because a test does not require any protection
on your spine. So this previous generation race
harnesses, the XR7, the Exo seat and the Carniva too.
They they went way over the required limit of the standard.
The standard requires very, very minimal protectors.
Those harnesses were building on the trust of pilots, building on
the market forces that pilots want something safe and nice and
protective. So they all had huge protectors.
I can show you the one in Exosite.
So look at that one. It's a monster.
So they went on like really building safety into their
marketing and the trust of pilots that if you land on your
ass with this protector, nothing happens.
Back then, actually lots of pilots regularly landed on their
harness because for them it was a safer option than possibly
having a bad step or something bad with with your knee.
So these protectors were were super reliable and super robust.
And this is you had a question about airbag versus foam.
I think the difference between the two is how much of that
abuse the foam protector can take.
But these protectors could take years of abuse.
I saw I saw Carneba harnesses with 1000 hours and it was still
in one piece. And so these ones took a lot of
abuse. The airbag could not take so
much abuse. But we are, if we are talking
about a single impact, like a single crash.
So let's say you're very careful you don't ever end on your
bottom unless it's a crash, then an airbag I believe is equally
good. Can you explain for our
audiences a little bit of a difference between airbag and
foam? Like what will help them make a
more responsible choice when they're going out and looking
for a protector, And then we'll switch over to origami and coir
and other offerings in the market.
So I wish this was the discussion today in the harness
selecting market. Like do you prefer an airbag?
Do you prefer a foam protector? Some harnesses can come with
both, like the the Woody Valley GTO, the Kanibarres they came up
with with an aftermarket protector years after the
harness was on the market. Now you can you can replace the
foam protector with an airbag. So those are those are really
nice choices. They have their advantages,
disadvantages. The airbag is lighter and
smaller. The foam can take more abuse.
But both of them are really good.
The problem is this is not the choice which many pilots are
having now. The choice is choroid versus in
competition harnesses. Right now there is no
alternative. So it's choroid versus choroid
versus maybe OK come as soon. So we are not even talking about
these known safe solutions when it comes to aerodynamic
harnesses. OK, we, we, we'll get to the
aerodynamic ones and, and the Creme Creme de la Creme, I like
to call it, because they're being flown by some of the
fastest racing pilots on this planet in our sport.
But let's let's talk about chair harnesses.
Chair versus pod except from the pendulum motion, except from the
twisting part that pod can twist easily.
The pendulum comes much more easily because your legs are
easy, like prone to more swaying.
Big major differences. Younger pilots should look out.
For when they're planning to upgrade, I think more than this
is in the harness geometry. And as I understand, they are so
complex that if you cannot just explain them and put them in two
categories. So I believe there are really
nice spots which of course a beginner should ask their their
instructor. So beginner should not just take
an advice from me or something online, they should ask your
instructor. But once they are above, I don't
know, 50 hours, whatever is the moment when they believe that
they should progress and and the glide starts to matter to them
then I think today there are loads of very nice safe, stable
pod harnesses. So I I would recommend people to
go with the pod. I don't.
At this point I don't see the point of going with a chair
harness too long. And and that is because it just
hampers your progression because like you will just get tired of
it pretty quickly. I just I just found flying more
enjoyable in port harnesses. Right.
It's really nice to fly in a port harness.
It's when it's cold you are not freezing.
But also the whole experience like turmaling and everything.
I mean I was one of the last holdouts because I had 1/4
Kamasutra too, which was which was a legendary chair.
Port El Kamasutra. OK, Yeah.
Yeah, extremely. It was called Kamasutra because
you can modify everything on it and and it was the only one
which I could find. I could perfectly set it on my
body and I really loved it. But then I went with an XR7 and
I fell in love. Yeah, I mean, XR7 is like I I
call it the Rolls Royce of the Sky Man.
So what I recommend to your viewers is ask around, ask
friends, maybe competition friends.
You don't have to choose the harness they fly, but they will
be able to tell you like some nice legendary harnesses.
Very nice harnesses. I'm actually so surprised that
Woody Valley hasn't discontinued XR7 because it's so damn heavy
that the target audience is more or less racing pilots and there
is not a single racing pilot on this planet that will give up
submarine style for the conventional one.
But I believe just because of how robust, safe and secure it
is, they're still having it in their inventory and still
offering it to the customers who want like no nonsense, your
safety and rugged long term oriented investment where XR7 is
answering their questions. I mean.
They probably only keep it because people are buying it.
So I think I, I, I would, I would guess that people still
buy XR Sevens, They still buy cannabis these days.
It's an interesting segment because they are probably not
like super final level pilots, but there is still a segment
which might still buy those harnesses.
Dude, I I feel like I could have bought XR7 as my very first
harness. The only drawback is forward
launches in this harness are a bit of a pain in the ass.
Like you know, early days, first 10 hours, 1st 20 hours when you
have all the butterflies in forward launch.
Like I learned in Himalayas where like in beer where the
wind is almost negligible. So every launch is a forward
launch and running in those Alpine conditions with like 15
kilograms on your back, you know, considering you have your
food and everything else in it as well.
That is the only drawback that I have.
But I, I, I feel like it wouldn't have made a big
difference had I gone directly to XR7 instead of having a GTO
Lite in between. But that's me.
I request the listeners and viewers to make their own
responsible choices. Hopefully this episode can help.
And keeping in line with that, I would, I would not know about
the other protectors that I've been offering.
Let's talk about origami and Koryeid.
To me, these are two different inventions.
Nevil do not invent origami, right?
What's the history of origami coming into parallel lighting,
do you know? I don't know too much.
I think Nevil did invent it. So I believe they have some in
house modeling, some in house 3D analytical software and they
designed, I mean the whole topic is called honeycomb protectors.
So honeycomb is like a geometrical structure and and I
think you can call call coroate A honeycomb even though it's
like parallel tubes then. So these kind of protectors are
probably there you have to general name, let's call them
honeycomb protectors. They are maybe 3D printed, maybe
some plastic glue together with this how coroate is made, but.
But the important thing is they have some kind of 3D structure,
whereas a foam is just just an everyday foam with more dense
than the ones we have in our beds.
But I believe origami is 3D printed, which has a big
advantage. They can perfectly tune those
parameters that cell size, the shape, the angles.
Like they can tune everything to a perfect use case.
So they can make an origami for lightweight pilots, for heavy
pilots, and they can optimize it for jerk, they can optimize it
for G. So it's actually looking like a
promising, promising new technology from NVU.
That is very interesting. I was just about to ask that
these two, what do you say new kind of entrants in the market
have been coming in from some of the biggest brands in the in the
industry. Like, you know, the adoption
which started with, I don't know if it was Jen who brought in the
Courier and then it got into Neo and then Ozone brought it in the
submarine because of how compact and streamline it is.
So these new protectors have challenged the status quo pretty
successfully and are seeing being widely adopted by the
market when in their lives we can take the measurement of
hours, after how many hours do you think a pilot is ready to
upgrade to these kind of protectors than the conventional
protection technologies that we have?
I believe at no point anyone should upgrade to coral it we
have a lot of evidence in the last 4-5 years.
We even had evidence before submarine came to market.
So January's 4 was one of the most one of the first mainstream
harnesses which use choroid. And I can show you like pilot
sharing on paragliding forum cases where the choroid
protector did not work for them. So I believe there is no hours
when a pilot should ever use choroid.
I very much hope that in the future we have standards which
do not allow the current version of Choroid to be flown.
Maybe Colloid comes up with an update, you know, 4.0 or
something, and then they fix those limitations of the current
versions. But I think the current versions
of Colloid is not not the safe material for harness back
protectors. It's made for bike hammets.
It's probably OK for bike hammets for parallel lighting
harness back protectors. I believe Colloid should not be
used in in today's version. Yes, I am OK.
Are these are any of these brands using it in the beginner
like chair harnesses or intermediate level harnesses as
well? Or is it just being applied in
the racing circles where streamline and drag and
everything is very important? I think Gin is the special one.
Gin fell in love with Choroid and they started putting it all
around the range. Lightweight harnesses,
intermediate harnesses I think Gin has.
I'm not sure but I believe Gin has Choroid all on their range.
Other harnesses still prefer forms and airbags for the non
competition harnesses. I'm just thinking that when this
was not discovered, like the security or the safety which we
had in XO and XR7 was like much more than what was required.
So there is a school of thought that says let's make it as
secure as possible because there's no limitation.
And then there's another school of thought which says that let's
make it as efficient as possible.
This brings me back to the thing that Kriegel Marr said a few
weeks ago. He said that we tend to chase
performance senselessly until we see something going bad.
And then we change, tend to chase safety senselessly until
we get bold of it. And then we go back to chasing
performance, which is perfect illustration of this.
I'm not sure. Maybe the audience members can
come in and let us know in the comments section what they think
about this paradigm shift in the mind where the manufacturers
have suddenly gone on to making it more efficient.
But, you know, like from your end, who has studied these
protectors? How do you rate origami?
And is it a ray of light? Or, you know, how do you call
it? I'm forgetting the idiom pair.
So let me answer the first like you had like 3 questions.
I want to answer them in disorder.
So first about you said there is like a philosophy of safety
versus the philosophy of efficiency.
I believe there has only been one force which has been acting
all the way and is acting today is the market force O Back then
when every harness was big and bulky, the market force was
choose or harness because it's the safest on the market.
So manufacturers were, you know, beating each other in safer and
safer harnesses. Everyone was flying super safe
harnesses. As I said, you could see some
videos from all the competition. Half of the pilots preferred to
land on their bottoms because it was so safe, so nice.
You could make a controlled landing a nice flare on the
bottom and there's like 0 risk of breaking your knees.
And so that was that was like an age of safety.
And until Ozone figured out that the submarine can really do this
generational gap in performance, at that point the market forces
were like, if I want to win, I have to buy this harness.
So it's always the market acting.
The market acting. When you believe that the
performance is similar, then you choose the safe one.
When you see that the performance is very much not
similar, you choose the one which allows you to win.
So it was always market forces. The interesting thing is the EN
test was never really strict. The EN test was a very, very
minimal test for harnesses. The harnesses for years were
very, very, very better than what the test required.
Test does not require spine protection.
Test does not require a lot of those things which those
harnesses were doing. The G limit is very higher in
the test than those harnesses. So they were kind of
enthusiastically beating and beating and beating their safety
values 1 brand over the other one.
Like people they were doing this who can get the lower G value on
a harness. And people were checking on the
forums and they said, wow, Exocit is great.
It has, I don't know, 36G or something very low value.
Even though the test required something over 45 or 50,
something extremely high. In practice, there was almost no
harness on the market, which was just doing the minimal test
criteria until submarine came on the market and turned everything
upside down because submarine was like, OK, what's the minimum
we can get away with? And maybe the philosophy was
that, by the way, the test has to be updated.
It's not our problem if the test is bad.
We are making a harness which is just fitting, just very, very
minimally passing the test. We are doing the most
aerodynamic harness which is passing the test.
And if there is a problem, the test should be updated.
That's what I can imagine was the philosophy of the very, very
early years, the prototype years of the submarine.
I don't think they ever imagined that there was, there would be a
time when Sea Sea Glider and SRS compilers are buying these
harnesses by the dozens. So I think it was more like an
experiment by Luke, more like a prototype experiment, you know,
making the next generation of paragliding.
And then maybe he hoped it by the time it gets very popular,
the standards would improve. So they control what can and
what cannot be in the harness. But the harness, the standard
did not improve. So that was your first or second
one. I totally agree with malware,
but we are not so unique in this.
So what I checked is every sport went through the same phases.
Bike helmets were introduced. They became mandatory after high
profile accidents and fatal accidents.
Skis were slowed down because of fatal accidents.
The surfers got like a life, a mandatory life vests, an
inflatable life vest. They were upset.
They were saying, come on, this is like we are not children.
But it improved their safety. So every sport goes through like
periods of of, of an unfortunate season.
And after that unfortunate season with a lot of safety
problems, the community comes together and they say let's
improve and then they improve. And then, you know, maybe 10
year passes and then they realise they have to improve
again. So I think it's an assurance
thing in sports that that is, this is how in every sport it
works. You, you, you don't over
regulate it unless you see some very serious issues, which tells
you now we have to regulate our sport.
And I believe this is exactly what's happening in our lighting
right now. OK, let's talk a little bit
about who is heading this because who is heading the
direction And I'll, I'll, I'll simplify it for our viewers.
Now we have pilots union, which is a beautiful place to sit and
talk and, you know, discuss and brainstorm and propose changes
to civil. Then of course we have civil and
the Basecamp groups. Basecamp is basically like an
application where you can chat. It's got a really cool name, but
it's all about chatting and brainstorming that is being run
by volunteers in civil, right? And on top of that, we have
European Norms, which is basically a testing laboratory,
which has been controlled by a work group and that work group
comes under the umbrella of civil and all of this is under
FAI. Is there anyone that I've missed
who can decide or influence harness and the safety that
comes with it? So I believe the working group
is not under the umbrella of civil.
These are independent organizations.
So one organization is FAI and CIVL and Total Independent.
One is the CEN, which is the EN group.
As I understand, it's founded by the European Union.
It's very much connected to European Union.
So it's very interesting for your international viewer to
know that all those rules about the whole global safety of the
sport is decided in a European Union group.
It's a, it's a funny, interesting thing.
And right now everything related to safety is controlled by this
group. So CIVL does not control it.
There is one exception, the CCC paragliding standard, which is
like, really, it's like an exception of the whole picture
because at that point it's something which CIVL controls
and those gliders which we fly on competitions, the CCC gliders
actually do not have an EN test. So those ones are certified
under a total different test. It's very much based on the
same, same roots, but this is an open standard.
And yeah, an interesting thing about the CEN group is that
traditionally they were selling standards like I call hardcover
books. And even in 2025, this is how it
works. So you cannot just go and read a
few pages of how is a harness tested.
The way is like you go online and you you can put in Google
you want to get this paragliding harness standard and then it
tests you. It costs €70 and we can send you
a book or we can send you APDF but.
It is a lowest group like a hard copy.
They were only selling a hard copy, not digital downloads as.
I understand this is the historical background of the
CEN. For many years they were selling
standards and maybe some of those working groups made money.
Now in our sport, I'm 100% sure no manufacturer makes a dollar
by selling those standards because who buys those
standards? The manufacturers buys, but the
manufacturer makes money by selling and choose their
product. So it's a very strange situation
now that no one can read the harness standard because of a
funny historical situation with the European funding of the CE
and group which controls the paragliding safety.
It's it's, it's behind a paywall basically.
Like you have to pay to read what the requirement is or what
the requirement says. Yes.
And the big problem with this is that you cannot just ask
independent, you know, medical researchers to please evaluate
the safety of our mandatory safety equipment in our sport.
I see everything is behind a paywall and it's going to have
to be like 60-70 euros for few pages of APDF.
So people cannot really look at it.
They are guessing based on, you know, small information shared
in online forums. And the DHV publishes something
and then you can read something from BH, but the actual standard
is never published and it's copyrighted.
Oh, so if you if you publish it, then you can be, you can have a
strike against a copyright strike for that.
Exactly. You cannot publish.
What I read, which might be a little work around, is that
member countries, let's say Germany, France can publish
explanations. They cannot use the same
drawings, but they can make a short summary document, they can
make an explanatory document. So maybe we can ask some of the
member countries, please, could you make a short explanation of
the standard, a short summary, and then they could actually
share those values and then we can refer to those values.
But the whole situation is just very much not 2025.
Like why is a mandatory safety equipment standard close behind
tables? Sounds weird to hear to be
honest, especially in such a niche like ours, you know, where
it's a handful of people looking after each other.
But let's talk about standards. What does the standard say that
is being so secretly guarded? So the current standard is
testing a drop test, which is they take they take like a a
vertical drop machine and they lift the harness to 1 meter, 65
centimeter and they let it fall on its protector.
And then they measure the acceleration value using a
sensor. And there are loads of problems
with this test which have been discussed for years.
One of them is it's a perfect vertical drop.
Now, if anyone saw a video about the paraglider crash or in real
life, you saw someone actually thrashing on the protector, one
thing is for sure, it's not perfectly vertical.
Like, yeah, yeah, when you stole a glider, when you are in a
lease side, when you something happens, when you are with the
rescue parachute and the wind blows, I would say 95% of the
cases it's not a vertical drop. But this is not the biggest
problem. The biggest problem, it only
tests, I believe the biggest problem is actually the weight.
So right now they tested the physical fixed weight of 50
kilograms. So no matter how big the pilot
is, the protector has only been tested with the 50 kilogram
dummy. And explain it to like 110
kilogram pilots that the protector on their back was
tested on a 50 kilogram dummy. OK.
I'm sorry to break a train of thought here.
EN has standards for paragliders as well.
And we have weight classification in paragliders
because with different weight, with different size, the canopy
behaviour changes substantially. You know the opening of the
outward cells on the wing tips and how the kind of cord and the
camber behaves and everything could be, could, could be
substantially different as we scale up the size and the whole
like internal structure of the paraglider.
But why are we not considering higher rate in harnesses when I
think this is not rocket science.
But if I just have to recall the physics class from my, you know,
junior high school, it was like vate adds more inertia, more
momentum to any object in motion.
And if we are having a drop test from 1.6 meters as you explained
with A50 kilogram dummy coming directly vertically down versus
120 kilogram dummy coming directly out directly down, I'm
pretty sure the acceleration values will be fairly different.
So aren't we in a way lying to heavier pilots, but basically
getting them to test reports of lighter pilots?
We are lying to both pilots. We are lying to both lightweight
pilots and heavier pilots. And I believe the the first step
in fixing the standard would be introducing weight ranges
exactly like liners. The manufacturer tests that this
protector is between 80 to 100 kilogram.
Then they have to do the tests. There is like a constant factor.
So an 80, let's say 100 kilogram pilot is not being tested for
the leg part. So I believe the right number
will be something like 80 because you are testing for your
hip and up, your ties and up because you say that the legs go
on the ground, you don't have to put the legs weight on the
protector. But you know the we can imagine,
I think a good standard which is targeting 100 kilogram pilots
would test with an 80 kilogram dummy.
So just just as your reference, and so let's say the upper
weight limit is 100 kilogram, the lower weight limit is 80
kilogram, then it should be tested with calculated dummy
weights on both of those points. Just like with the gliders, we
should do exactly the same philosophy as to the glider
tests. And this should have been done
by the CEN committee that has the EN tests like this is this
is not air turquoises or DHVS, aerial responsibility or not
even civil. This has to come from CEN which
has the working group. It should have.
It should have came from CEN working group.
Yes, there have been a lot of feedback over many years about
the limitations of their tests and they have been working on an
updated standard and it seems like a new standard is coming
out next year which is not addressing any of those
limitations which people communicated to them.
But yes, they are the 11 owner of the standard and they should
fix their standard, yes. There is a new standard coming,
but deliberately ignoring what the community has been asking
for is is this what you just said?
I don't know deliberately or not, but at the end of the day
they ended up with the standard draft, which does not address
any of the criticism. It addresses some points which
was not a problem, like the G limits.
It was not a problem that the harnesses were already under
those G limits they proposed. So they address something which
was really not a critical problem and they just totally
avoided answering the hard questions, the weight limit, the
spine protection, the horizontal component and the jerk test.
So none of those were solved. I see.
I see, before I talk to you about The Who forms working
groups, I want to talk to you like, you know, you can consider
this if, if this was off the record, like nobody was
listening to us. And it's up to you if you want
to answer this or not. But do you have any idea why
such a basic fundamental need for safety is being overlooked
and solutions are which are being provided on addressing the
concerns anyways? Like why would somebody do this
man? It baffles my mind.
Like you know, all of us want the skies to be more fun and
more safe place to be. I believe most of them are
volunteering and most of them in this group.
I don't know what's happening in this group, but I mentioned it's
also like a mailing list or something where some brands are
putting more effort, some brands are putting less effort.
And it's, it's maybe it's like base camp just in their version.
And I can imagine that most of them are just very, you know,
they don't put too much effort in fixing the standard.
There is no pressure on the group.
CIBI puts 0 pressure on them. So they don't really have to.
And I think at one point it's like who is more active?
And I can imagine that some members of the group are very
active and they push it in a direction which is not what the
pilot's feedback is. So I can imagine at one point
that there are reasons to push it in the direction of not
having a jerk test. Because if you don't have a jerk
test, you can get 7 centimeter protectors, then the solution is
choroid or origami. And there is a you know, there
is a lot of reasons to push for that direction when only choroid
and origami and these kind of honeycomb materials can work.
I actually love the way you explained it, that you know,
because we're not finger pointing here at anyone.
We're just trying to bring out the information to a larger
audience who has been unaware of what's going on.
But I followed your e-mail trail and I'm not trying to put you in
a spot field. The whole idea is to try and
bring out credible information from somebody who has been in
the thick of things. Your e-mail trail was fairly
long and it basically said that jerk standard which you
mentioned, which we will come to more details in the in the next,
you know segment. But when you said include jerk
or when others had their similar kind of suggestions, what was
the answer given when they were ignored out of the final draft
that is coming next year like that is, it's quite frustrating.
I'm trying to look at it from your point of view.
You know, you invest time, energy and money voluntarily.
Everyone is volunteer. So we, I think we have to stop
coming up with the volunteer example because nobody is
professional in these setups except from a handful of people.
So everybody is at the same level.
So you yourself have put in the effort, but what is the excuse
maybe is the right word given to you for not including your your
suggestions in the final draft that is coming out next year?
So we had the back and forth about jerk value services not
and as I said before, it's interesting, it wasn't even my
idea. It was Josh, another pilot in
the working group who introduced me to the jerk measurement and
the the fillers of the definition of jerk.
And then also we had medical researchers on the team and
everyone agreed that the human body has upper tolerable limit
for jerk. It's a super important criteria,
just like we have an upper tolerable limit for G values for
acceleration. So the the pilots, an
independent part of the working group verse 100% agreeing about
importance of jerk. And then the manufacturers also
looked into it. And at the end there were two
reasons. So for us, the we had a big, I
personally always had the opposite points with Niveuk.
Niveuk was always sharing the NASA study about the G values
acceleration and they were sharing it, I don't know, dozens
of times always explaining we need lower G and lower G and
lower G And I said, look, we are looking at the very same NASA
study. We are looking at the same pages
and then the pages say your human body can tolerate this
much G and the human body can tolerate this much jerk.
If you go over the jerk, you break the vertebrae.
It's been tested. It's not a philosophical, you
know, experiment. It's been actually tested in the
real bird airplane pilots in the 1960s that they had this rocket
ejection seats and the ones which had two high jerk, they
broke the vertebrae. They had compression fractures.
So it's been a very practical, real word tested hard results,
hard numbers from the NASA study, and we are looking at the
same study and they believe that we only look at the G and at the
very end of this discussion, there were two reasons why we
shouldn't do it, Nevyuk said. They looked into it, they run
their calculations and they believe that if we go for the
jerk for you, then the harnesses would be very large.
I mean. What if everybody flies large
harnesses? Yes, that's the next yes.
I think at this point everyone in the competition scene arrived
at your conclusion that now we move to submarine, everyone is
on submarine, We have zero advantage compared to each
other, except everyone has tiny 6 centimeter protectors.
So the whole sport relative to each other is still the same,
except now we are all not safe because of the lack of proper
protectors. So yes, it would bring bigger
protectors. So that was one reason.
The second one was the measurement is not precise.
Now. I looked into it, I spent a year
afterwards and this autumn I again invested time and I
developed the software and I asked Fred from Ozone.
He was very nice and he sent me some measurement files and I can
say that you can measure extremely precisely that jerk
mesh is not a problem. I I don't even know which
tangent to go out on Jolt. OK.
I think we should sort of what I think is important and I think
your question was about is that if we do not measure jerk, then
we are down to 7 centimeter protectors.
If we do measure jerk, we are about 13 centimeter protectors
and at the 7 centimeter range there is no alternative to
choroid and or economy. OK, this is this is brand new
information for me to process and also probably some of the
listeners can think resonate in this guys, please let us know in
the comments. What do you think about the
discussion so far? I think the only way both like
me, you, him and everybody else around us can collectively make
this safety thing a norm is by at least speaking about it, at
least talking about it. The more we talk, the better
possibilities of doing things after talking.
But regardless, let's talk about G and jerk.
Please feel free to share your screen if you want to.
I want people to understand how G changes with jerk.
OK, so I shared my screen and you can see very similar
drawings this trapezoid in the NASA study back from.
And so we are talking about some such as in research for decades,
for more than half a century. And what you see here is 3 steps
going up, then just going horizontal and going down.
And let me explain this concept on something we can back to.
It's a car and a look. So you're driving on a highway
with 120 kilogram kmh and you realize there is a traffic jam
in front of you. So you have to brake.
You do a big strong braking, but you don't make an emergency
braking. So you are not like 100% brake.
You have to stop in relatively short distance.
So what you do first start pushing the brake pedal smoothly
and then at one point you keep the brake pedal on that bane
that let's say 800 or something of your possible travel without
locking the the wheels. And then at the end you let the
brake pedal up. So this is exactly the
definition of jerk, the the point where you're pushing down
the brake pedal smoothly. This is just the change of
acceleration. This is a smooth acceleration
and in the harness we have smooth acceleration, but it's
the same concept. So you start braking smoothly.
What happens if you don't brake smoothly?
You just slam on the brakes. All of your passengers would
have this strong whiplash movement of their of their neck
and they could feel uncomfortable and painful.
So this is very important to understand what's happening in a
hardness because the current test is this the current test.
The G measurement is just this middle parts, G limit part in a
car that would be like staying on.
It turns out the human body is not so sensitive to staying on a
break. You can choose a bigger value,
you can choose a lower value. It's not so big of a deal.
The big deal is the change going from nicely travelling at 120 to
going into this breaking. This whole change between the
two get very sensitive to that. And the NASA study was showing
the same and actually what's missing from the two day and
test and what's the problem with choroid that they don't have a
smooth deceleration like a foam or an airbag has this very nice
and soft and smooth going from nothing happens to being on the
ground and being pushed. They have this nice gradual
connection between the two. Choroid does not has.
Choroid is like a plastic which is crumpling which is being
destroyed and until it starts being destroyed it's solid or
almost solid object. Got it.
But you know, I do want to come back to Choroid on its
importance and future of power lining harnesses.
But can we visualize the jerk value versus the G value for any
harness out there in the market right now that you might have
seen, umm, in your research so far?
I wish we would get to a point where everyone could just easily
check the harness before purchase.
They can check for both the G and the jerk values.
In Today Ian test, you go to Barra test and you look for the
harness. That's what a lot of pilots do
and you go to that page which shows the G value and you look
for the G value. You can already do this for the
G value. I believe jerk value is just as
important and it should be equally shown on those pages.
Did have you had a chance to know jerk value of any current
offerings in the market which which can help us you know get
an idea about how jerk varies with G?
So in theory, everyone could do it.
In practice, it's a very time consuming thing.
But the jerk is exactly the the smoothness or the difference of
acceleration. Because the acceleration this
this kind of graphs which you see on the screen.
Now these are published, you can actually zoom in and you can
precisely measure where the points are in time.
What am I looking at? I'm I'm so confused.
There's 2.22 point 4 and there's a blue line, a red line and a
green line. OK.
So this is this is when you look at the harness test, you go on
para test, you put in the name of the harness and this is what
you've, this is like this for many years now.
OK. And what happens here, this is
exactly the acceleration of the drop test.
You have like a first a big hit, then it goes to a maximum G
value. You can see it goes up to
something like 33 or I don't know, something like that.
So it goes to AG value, then a smaller and a smaller one
because it always bounces a bit, but we are concentrating on the
first one. So so the yellow line, sorry
just just go back to that one again.
The yellow line is desirable. GI think I think this was
mentioned in the NASA study. No the.
NASA study is here, yes, so this is you can also see the
trapezoid which I was doing on this visualizer website which I
was showing before. So another study is very clear.
Human body has a tolerance for G and for jerk.
So they have a lot of values here.
They say the jerk is 115 preferable 118 preferable 500
tolerable 1000, no permanent injury.
One percent 300 is the absolute, absolute tolerable upper limit
over multiple studies. And they came up with these
numbers. So yeah, what I wanted to say is
that you can calculate those jerk.
It's very difficult, but you can you can download the files, zoom
in with some software and you can measure exactly how fast is
the acceleration. And then this is what kind of
values I came up with. I tested just a few harnesses
because it's time consuming. So right now let's let's say.
Fuck bro. So oh, let's these are the jerks
and you know, the NASA had this 1300 and to my biggest surprise,
the previous safe previous generation race harnesses like
1/4 Carnival, also an exo seat, they were all less than 1300.
They were exactly somehow manufacturers found exactly the
safe value, which NASA found the safe value without I'm sure
knowing about jerk or jerk measurement or NASA study just
empirically like testing and testing and testing.
They came up with the same numbers.
So Carnival and the exo seat are both less than 1300.
And then we have the choroid based ones multiple times like
submarine is 8000. That's insane man, that's a huge
jump. It's a huge jump and it's way
over the safe limit. Of course, I would love to get
the actual measurement of these harnesses and we could see if
they are precisely what you know, it might be 8000, it might
be 6000, but it's very clear. It's very clear that the
measurement cannot be that bad, and very clear if we are talking
about multi multiples of the safe value for colorate
harnesses. OK.
I want you to just go back to that graph where you had put the
comparison side by side. Yeah, these these two.
So could you please tell our listeners what they're looking
at? So this is the test, this is the
test you download from para test of every harness.
Every harness is protected or they have to upload these
graphs. Now I call our, I believe it was
maybe the Carnival with red and the blue was the submarine.
It's one of the old harnesses versus the submarine.
And what you can see is the red 1, the old test of the carnival,
you can see it's a smooth curve. So you can see what happens is
that the harness is being dropped and then it's smoothly,
smoothly starts getting compressed and it's acting like
a spring. The more you compress it, the
more force it gives you various. And this gives you this this red
shape which has has a nice you see a nice little angular smooth
start. I would say nicer.
It by no means look nice, but. Completely doesn't look nice.
Yeah, but compared, just compare it to that corner.
The corner is the corner is that the choroids are not being
crushed. So the pressure is getting more
and more and more. And they are not crushed, not
crushed, not crushed. And at one point the pressure is
so much that they crumple. So this is how choroid works.
Choroid has this, this, this huge step in the beginning.
And the problem with that is that choroid can give you low
GS. That's not a problem.
The the the emoji is the top of it.
But no one is talking about this corner.
No one is talking about what happens, how smooth is our is
our crash. OK, so wait a second.
This is choroid when it is supposed to work perfectly.
That is what the. That's a very good point.
That's a very good point. Holy shit.
So this is a choroid which actually got scrambled because
as we will see there are loads of examples when choroid did not
crumble and pilots broke a vertebra.
So this is like the most optimum case for choroid.
So if everything goes right, you will still endure a jerk of 8000
or 6000. Exactly if everything.
Goes right. Oh my God dude I'm so sorry I'm
laughing. It was scary to just listen to
it. And no one made a test for what
happens when the color it is not compressed I.
Don't want to buy a Colorado? No.
The way it first. Currently in the sport, we, we
are in the dark ages, we are sending WhatsApp, WhatsApp
messages to our friends in hospitals and during recovery
stage. They are pilots.
They have been pilots on on Brazil where championship who
still hasn't been started in August and they still hasn't
recovered from compression, vertebral compression.
They have so serious injuries from just a normal landing on a
coroid which would have not been a serious issue with the
previous generation harnesses. I feel like we should have a
database of harness impacts as well.
Like we keep on talking about glider accidents being recorded,
but nobody talks about RNS. But like, do you know, like, how
many people have, like, how many people have successfully saved
their assets from Korea? I don't know, but what I do know
is it's very interesting. So I believe let's you imagine
you have a big accident. Imagine you have a big accident
and you maybe you get disabled. So what's the chance that you go
on paragliding forum and you post your most people at this
point, you know, doesn't want to look at Parrot Landing anymore.
They just want to give up on. So still we have a lot of pilots
who publicly shared that what happened with the corrid and
basically what happened is that didn't compress at all.
And I want to show you some photos now.
So for example here this is a photo, look at this corrid.
That's that's from a normal like.
That's how the projector is supposed to look like.
So no, this is exactly how it's not supposed to look like.
It should be compressed because this one is also, this is after
impact. This is a crash.
And this was one of the earliest reports in Paragraphic Forum
before submarine came out, before Genie Race 5.
So this was still Genie Race 4. Maybe you've just started using
corrids and it was one of the most popular racing at that
point. It was only racing Carnot.
We should call it. And then a pilot said look at me
Sir. Said myself had a serious crash
right on the choroid. I fractured 1 vertebrae in my
back with paralysis in my pelvic area and legs.
The choroid wasn't even deformed.
Sorry but beware of this protection that is used in
multiple harnesses now. So I believe there have been
hundreds of accidents where the choroid was not deformed in a
choroid state intact. This whole material only works
if you it's a single use material.
It only works if you crash it and you destroy it and how it
dissipates the energy. If it looks like this, you can
for 100% say that it did not dissipate energy.
I do clearly remember Eric from Flynn Neo telling me.
I mean, for those of the listeners who are wondering
about this episode, you know, just feel free to go down in the
Index and you will find Eric from Flynn Neo in the in the
catalog there. But he said that courtyard is
being scrutinised because it is visible.
The damage is visible. But what you are telling me is
that the damage doesn't even happen.
Like the damage is not visible. So it's like very conflicting
way to understand, you know, how this protector made.
It So, yeah, if you are having a crash with a choroid, what you
want, you want to look at the protector and say I have to
throw this out. It worked.
It saved my life. I crumpled it.
It's destroyed. Now it's time for me to replace
it. But this is not what happens.
What is happening is pilots are finding their choroid protectors
intact, which means they did not provide protection.
And there is a famous case of Nick, half a million views on
YouTube, who got disabled, unfortunately after a
paragliding accident, but he survived.
And then after a while he shared his coroid and you can see that
the coroid in his harness looked almost like this.
Some of them were rotated, so some of them were on the sides,
but none of them had this this official crashed state, which is
on the coroid website. You go on the Coroid website and
then they show you nice animation and beautiful things
about how how a crashed coroid works.
And there are so many cases where none of the protectors
actually got crashed, but the pilots got disabled or they had
very serious long lasting spine injuries.
So if you know for sure that it does not work, these scoroid
protectors do not fit their requirement.
They do not protect the pilots. Did they revise the protection
protector from once it was introduced at the beginning?
Like have have there been? Because I'm pretty sure this
feedback has been communicated to the people in charge and
there are others who must have looked at it with like the same
eyes as you. Has there been any sorts of
revisions in the design or like what are the efforts that have
been made to address correlate problems?
I can say for sure not adequate the solutions.
I mean they put version number score rate 1.22.03.0, those kind
of things. But in the latest versions, in
the latest June, January 5, the correlate is just as bad as it
was before. So we have those pilots from
World Championships and many of those who we know unofficially,
because officially nothing is communicated with unofficially
between each other. We are chatting.
Some of them were on the latest gene harness with the latest and
the greatest choroid version. It still doesn't work.
OK, so to make it easier, any dissipation of energy has to be
sideways and spread out. Does does that make sense?
So it doesn't matter. At the end of the world, we
don't care about what happens with energy.
We want something on a harness which somehow protects.
It might be an airbag. You know that airbag, the
pressure goes higher and it bounces back.
Or if you put a valve on it and then it lets the air out, you
can have a foam which acts like a spring.
So at the end of the day, we don't care how it's solved.
You're very open. I believe the new standard
should be super open for innovation as long as those
criteria of acceleration and jerk is fulfilled.
So Coroid does not fulfil the jerk criteria even if.
I'm also wondering like the side impacts and the spreading out
because when I was at Coroid's website, all the impacts were
showing it crumpling directly at the point of contact.
But let's say if we are having a side impact in parallel lining,
which is fairly common, like almost, it's hypothetical to
expect to fall directly down straight up.
Coroid does not have side crumpling properties and at the
same time. It bottoms out much lower than
foam. So are these two.
One of the biggest challenges that the technology has that it
is covering only one directional impact and it is bottoming out
fairly quicker, which eventually is resulting in higher jerk and
whatever. So there are two 2 problems that
correct one. We discussed that even if it
works, even if it crumples, it generates such a high jerk that
it's not in the tolerable a bit of human.
But the bigger problem is in most of the cases it doesn't
work. And why it doesn't work, one of
the reason is for example, when it has the side horizontal
component or an angular hit, it turned out many of these tubes,
they don't really compress if the hit is arriving like 45° or
something. This is what we we know from
these pilots. But in the real verge, in the
real life crashes with a rescue or without a rescue, the pilot
is not coming down perfectly vertical because that's how the
real life is. We have wind, we have rescue
parachute, we have maybe a stalled glider.
We are in all kind of let's say 45°.
It's probably a much better approximation than a perfect
vertical drop. So it turns out that Choroid is
testing the vertical drop versus in the real world pilots are
having all kind of realistic impacts from all directions and
Choroid does not compress when it comes from a direction.
So that's the two biggest problem.
I call, right? I mean, I was, I was going to
ask, do you think origami will solve this?
But I think the answer to that is only time will tell.
But you'll, you know, we can keep going back and forth on
this, but I hope we have given enough information to audiences
on how to be more responsible. But what is the way forward from
yours? Your eyes, you know.
How do you see us flying with more Peace of Mind and time to
come. So what we have to realize is
that the EN working group is doing OK work with the lot of
part of the sport. You know our gliders I believe
we fly today are safe and nice and it's a good direction we are
going in. But some aspect necessarily what
I mean here is this life critical equipment or safety
critical gear like those equipment you're not expected to
test, you're not expected to try out.
You hope it works in a car. Analogue I would say is the
airbag. No one knows if we don't know if
the airbag works in a car. The only way you can learn if it
works is either you are in an accident or your friend is in an
accident and you ask them in the hospital and how was the airbag?
So these are the things you're not expected to try out.
And I believe we have to manage these kind of life critical gear
in a totally different way than the rests how we manage the rest
of the sport. So in our sport it's hard, it's
hardness back protectors. Hardness back protectors should
not be just 100% trusted on the manufacturers group because they
have shown and shown and shown again they do not address those
problems which they got asked about and they got a lot of
feedback. I believe a lot of manufacturers
have a mini database about choroid accidents.
Pilots contact their dealers. The dealers contact the
manufacturer directly. They have information that it's
not working, but they keep it silent and they are not
improving it. And I looked into it and in
many, many other sports, in Motorsports, in skiing, in
biking, in so many sports in American football, this, this
safety critical equipment is, is handled in a totally different
way. It's always independent from the
manufacturers. Usually they have their, their
mother organization, which is FAI or CIBI for us.
It's almost always controlled on the mother organization level.
So for for car drivers and motorbike drivers and bicycle
races, the helmet standard is not by the manufacturers.
The helmet standard is by the by the organization, independent
organization. Same in the car for roll cages
in the skis, the skis were slowed down not because the
manufacturers wanted to slow it down, because the organization
decided that for safety they have to implement new criteria.
So a lot of these standards are not controlled by the
manufacturers. I believe they run the same
circles we are running now. Decades ago, decades ago, they
realised that manufacturers can be trusted with a lot of things
but when it comes to safe, critical equipment, they should
not be trusted. We have to control it ourselves.
And you're talking about EN group is basically filled with
the kind of mixture of people out of which some are more
active than the others and they are driving it in a certain way,
which is more manufacturer oriented than safety oriented.
I believe, I don't know, someone will tell me, but I believe
right now the EM group is 100% manufacturers.
I don't believe there is a single medical researcher there,
independent pilots. So it's not an independent
group. It's, it's something which
consists of manufacturers. Right now, maybe in other sports
with much bigger budgets, they actually have researchers and
doctors and you know, people with different opposite views in
the EM group. I believe in paragliding the EM
group is manufacturers. So we and it's normal, the
normal that the manufacturers are trying to push for the
market forces. We shouldn't expect them not to.
This is how everything works. What's not normal is that the
CIBL trusts the safety critical gear on the EN group.
Safety critical gear standard should not be on the EN group.
It should be. Ideally it should be a standard
of the CIBL or something independent.
And shouldn't take €70 to have access to this, for fuck's sake.
Of course it should. Be an open standard and any
medical researcher and any pilot can should be able to go on a
website and understand what harness back protector standard
means, exactly how it has those brake protectors.
I don't mean everything should be opened up.
I would glider testing and whatever.
I'm just saying that it's very much exactly the the precisely
the back protector standard should be an open and
independent standard. I think that's the only way
forward in our sport. You know what this is seeming
like seemingly like a never ending topic, Uh, but I'm pretty
sure listeners who have stuck with us so far have gotten
plausible takeaways from our talk to date.
And all I can say is that, yeah, man, I hope things become more
transparent and the paragliding Atlas is here to bring your
voice or anybody else's voice out to the masses if it matters.
So to anybody who's listening to this, feel free to reach out
with your thoughts. Drop in your comments or if you
feel like you can throw some more light on the topic and
would like to be a guest on the show, shoot me an e-mail and
hopefully keep our fingers crossed that working group goes
in the right direction after the next upcoming the region.
Thank you very much. It was wonderful to be on your
show.